how'd you like that movie it was pretty
intense hi guys my name is Tamra
chambers and this is Tamra's ever seen
and today I am watching jaws for the
first time this has been one that I knew
I was gonna have to conquer at some
point during its show and I'm putting it
off it's just it's a shark movie right
like I don't know not very excited I
wasn't very excited about it um but I
was surprised we'll get into it look at
it to it but yeah and watch jaws with I
already did this just the intro guys Oh
Tanner has never seen magic filming
anyway yay so the movie starts off with
a group of like high school kids college
kids I don't know smoking weed playing
guitar drinking beer making out at the
beach brings me back just kidding I was
too busy in that high school production
of Seussical the musical to do anything
that was illegal so they're at the beach
and this girl fleur-de-lis jumps in the
ocean with this guy she's like chase me
and she runs down the beach and she
starts swimming I think that is not how
I've learned there's no physical
activity or sports in my flirting so if
we're doing sports together chances are
I'm not flirting with you so desks just
like a heads up oh my god and then she
just starts getting drugged under oh
shit oh no like okay I knew this is
where this was going but oh no
so they wake up the next day and you see
the belief cheese it cheese please
cheese and his family and their family
is so cute super great then you see his
car forget his family that is so cute
and great can I have that like a
convertible Jeep truck I love that car I
want that car
give me that car can I have it
I have it can I have it so then there's
this very dramatic scenes you see that
the girl's arm is in the sand and they
have found her eaten by the shark you
like to eat shark is that officially you
like to eat do you want one of my rings
so that you can be a stylish as me
you're so stylish you guys see that
look at how stylish shoes so the police
chief Martin is trying to figure out how
to close the beach when he finds out
there's a bunch of Boy Scouts out in the
ocean swimming today for fun let's see
how prepared they are for this now the
Boy Scouts died thankfully but this
terrible mayor character shows up and
tells the police that he can't the the
chief Martin that he can't close down
the pool the pool there's sharks of the
pool he can't close down the beach
because it's there tourists time and
it's an island and they need the money
and so Wow money rules all good like the
weekend before fourth of July beaches
packed and honestly I'm just very
concerned about the black lab that's
swimming in the ocean
don't kill the black lab please then you
see the scene where he goes that's some
bad hat harry
like that was familiar house look at how
he's sleeping right now he's like I'm
trying to sleep
maniac shut up so then of course I can't
get Deaton the police chief is just
standing there because he doesn't go in
the water
apparently he's afraid of it even though
he lives on an island
okay so then they put a bounty out for
the shark three thousand dollars to kill
the shark and he goes to close the beach
and the town goes ballistic like they're
so mad at Martin for closing the beach
it's like did you not did you all not
just see that motherfucking kid getting
mother beaten by a mother shark that
doesn't make sense
doesn't make sense doesn't make sense
then you see this hilarious seafaring
character come out is like I'll show
that shock literally ten thousand
dollars I'm old and seafaring and tough
and I live at the same island that all
of you do but I haven't got a different
voice than you do because I'm seafaring
the sea sharks the town is like no we're
not gonna pay $10,000 for this shark we
don't even believe it's real open the
beaches
and some inexperienced fishermen go out
so they can get the $3,000 and it's not
good there's a lot of slow building
menacing music and then no one addresses
it there's like yes still it's fine
we're still good still still only two
people in Bonita it's not that big of a
deal
those skipper guy Matt from the ocean
something Institute comes to help and he
is a GD delight and she is pissed at
everyone for being was so stupid he's
like wait you're the police chief and
you didn't go out on your own to it for
the Sharks oh you've never seen it also
no one called the Coast Guard also no
one's doing anything so then one of the
random fisherman catches a shark
obviously not the shark and Matt is not
impressed Matt from the ocean something
Institute not feeling it so Matt
convinces Martin that it's not the shark
but the mayor still won't let them tell
anyone he's like don't put a damper on
this day he doesn't have an accent but I
just might imagine he doesn't my mind so
then the mom of the little boy who died
comes and slaps the police chief just
like you knew that there was a shark in
the waters and you didn't close the
waters why I'm like yeah that is valid
and it shouldn't be Martin getting
blamed for it because it was the mayor
but somebody should be getting blamed
for this so Martin is sad he's at home
eating dinner sadly and Matt comes by
with wine and He pours why he's like how
was your day it's like this is like
relationshipgoals like are they falling
in love right now I love them is that a
thing that's been addressed in a lot of
other like jaws forums that Matt and
Martin are the best love story of all
time because it should be and in their
love Matt motivational speaks the crap
out of Martin and gets him to go out on
a boat even though he's afraid of the
water because he drowned as a kid so
much backstory he finds this awesome
huge tooth proving that it's a great
white shark which is not common for
where they are and then he also sees a
dead man so then he drops the truth
because dead man and there's great music
building this whole time and I was
literally stress eating pistachios this
entire time and this fourth of July and
the place is packed and they spot a
shark but it's only kids with like a
little shark thing on kids are the worst
but then
the shark is in the pond area of the
beach and that is where Martin's
children are at so Martin's kids are
fine but the shark does eat someone in
that pond area and you see the shark for
the first time I'm gonna call the shark
Fay I think that's a good name for a
shark so you see Fay and you're like
shit Fay you your big girl Fay yeah the
ocean is so scary you come so they
finally come to their senses and they
hire the seafaring hilarious guy his
name is Quint and they go out on the
ocean quit Matt and Martin cutest
threesome there ever will be
so they shoot the shark with this cool
like harpoon and it's got a floaty
barrel on the end and apparently it's
super hard for the Sharks to be
underwater for a long time with the
Barrow ups they get tired it's so
buoyant and they're like cool we'll wait
it out we got one barrel on them let's
just keep it out of going and so they go
in and share wonderful scary stories
about sharks together adorable sweet no
come back so long as she ever sat next
to me for cameras ever seen go back to
my remote place now but then Fay comes
back and she is pissed
she is wreck and shit-faced hair and
shit apart they shoot her with two more
barrels and then they tied the barrels
to the boat she's pulling the boat she
rips the barrels off Fay is beautiful
and smart and she deserves better than
the bucket treatment barrel buckets
treatment poor Fay so then quit kind of
goes mad and he's pushing the boat super
past where it should go
the engines are giving out Fay is
chasing them super fast and the engines
give out and the boat starts sinking
it's very stressful stakes are high so
the mat goes in this terrible cage of
death and he's got poison for the shark
and they jump in and then and then Fay
knocks the poison off of the cage and
then starts eating the cage and you see
the mat is a goner but mat goes and
hides under a little Barrier Reef thing
you know one of those you know Barrier
Reef's then Fay jumps on the boat and
eats quince and it's horrific
is horrifying she's chomping on it and
and and and Oh God Martin is like
watching it happen and he's afraid of
the ocean in the water and this is just
the worst case scenario for him or
anyone in the world except for Feifei
gets a meal so it's good for Fay and at
this point Martin thinks he's alone he
thinks that mat has died and he
definitely saw quince died and so the
boat is sinking he doesn't like the
water and there's this giant man-eating
shark so it's a great Tuesday the whole
boat is under water and he's like on the
very top and he's shooting it Fay and
then he finally gets like this gas tank
like in her mouth and then shoots that
and she explodes and it's flipping
awesome he's like smiling son of a bitch
Oh suck it Fay then Matt swims up and
Martin realizes that he's alive and
honestly they are so adorable
they paddle back to shore at the end of
the movie love story all along between
Matt and Martin they're adorable John
Williams is incredible the tension that
he builds with his music is just ah so
good we all know this already but gosh
dang you think you go it you go into
this movie thinking that you know
exactly what it is makes you do it's a
flippin Shark Attack movie like I know
what was going to happen
I knew but it was really well done I am
really glad that it's like they watched
it I think there's like other movie
other job movies and I won't be watching
those I don't think so next week I am
going to do a movie that I kind of
wanted to do for tambour fest and didn't
get a chance to Creepshow Doug told me
about it and I'm very interested piqued
my curiosity I guess it's five different
little vignettes and it's Stephen King
whatever I'm very excited about that
also that it's a like less known movies
I think people are getting a little
upset and seeing these bigger ones and
there are some bigger ones coming in
December so
I'm gonna do what a little less
well-known for next week but to kind of
offset the upsetness that some of you
are feeling yesterday I posted an
episode of Tamra has seen on my personal
channel Tamra L chambers at youtube.com
I'm just explaining one of the movies
that I grew up with that I really
enjoyed why I enjoyed it um not really
review II just a little reviewing
whatever guys it's it is what it is but
anyways thank you for watching this
video
tune in next week for creep show Stephen
King spooky very excited you guys are
awesome Takia soon